walk him to this video Paul du jour one
of the frequent opponents he recently
caught up a bit and score against me I
had a super squirrel and lost but lost
the last two lost the last two games
going to play an very very technical
idea of their Catalan or exposing them
oh this is this is a pleasant surprise
night Texas is much better
the problem is that black has some a big
issue him he he does not get the C porn
into play I can always some block the
pawn let's see 92 maybe
494 yeah maybe maybe he has some nights
e4 available hmm you might also have a 5
92 94 I can take also see form Queen
takes 93 and this is not really
convincing 92 94 with the bishop of
weight is not really into much you see 5
a problem though
it's not a real problem but still I
would have liked to improve nth that mmm
92 nite see form
Jim how to how to do that hmm ok so he
gets in you five if you want I mean it's
not clear that he wants to play the move
ok now i have 90 for gt5 always not
going for that at all weird okay f5 is a
very committal move of course now i know
i have very nice control em i can even
just take it
okay to keep it keep it simple just just
take this okay first the night maybe so
that there is no rookie 3 or any any
funny stuff happening now here yeah I've
very graphic could play on the sea for
now it basically has to take now what do
five is the target or a six sandals
night before as a moose one possible
move and 95 s also also in the air
it's very difficult to our to defend
night before working here right away
double attacking d 5 and a 6 yeah I
think but this was probably almost
impossible to defend okay I can take
yeah this is easiest gym check I also
windy 5 check
black resigns yeah then this line is
very problematic but I thought probably
I did something tell me something wrong
Bishop f6 is is a mistake in this
position you must go oops you must take
with the 90 m and this gives some black
quite good equalizing chances ultimately
yeah here we get exactly this and this
is very very uncomfortable went here III
looks good Queen d6 maybe I can maybe
still 92 I I was afraid of light C for
him but nighty voice good ah this I
didn't really consider a 94 strong yes
yeah that's it's very very much clearer
if we look at this now I have this
smooth and he only has this kind of
reply yeah with a with a fantastic
position here having having him blocked
on the sea farm and I a now I thought a
thought here he would go fe5 I thought
this should give black white okay
chances I wanted to take and then just
develop like this I still have 94 ideas
and I'm a bit i'm a bit more coordinated
but better coordinated he's got this
funny look on a seven and i'm somewhat
quicker with rookie one so it's probably
still good for in the ledge 0.6 by the
comp but yeah it gets ugly and after f5
it's worth very ugly I don't see him
ever playing e5 NTM this is I think
instructive just get rid of the the d5
night and limit a black skull to play
I think we takes what a bit a bit
tougher I could have taken f5s I just
only now see that but okay i was i was
going for this tool to control him I
simply didn't see that f5 was hanging I
was aiming for this position and here
the 92 d3 is basically winning night
before yeah this was wasn't the toughest
defense but I think like check it's not
going to going to keep the pawn sium
there are simply too much pressure this
this this it's too much and the bishop
is not helping in defense at all okay
thanks for watching